you might be wondering is pinterest an
effective platform for creators well
here are three reasons why you should
start using pinterest in 2021 especially
if you are a creator discoverability
collaboration and monetization confused
don't worry i am going to explain
everything to you
[Music]
hi guys my name is talha and i'm a
graphic design instructor and just like
most other creators out there i also had
a really hard time getting my work
discovered and recognized but then i
understood the power of pinterest and i
started getting 8 million monthly
visitors on my profile let's dive into
the first reason and that is
discoverability so pinterest is one of
the best platforms if you want to get
your work discovered not only on the
platform but also of it so what do i
mean by that firstly pinterest is a type
of platform where people come to get
ideas and inspiration so if you know how
to use keywords and hashtags on it
properly you will start getting tons of
traffic and secondly pinterest itself is
a highly optimized platform on google so
yes i'm talking about search engine
optimization that means your content on
pinterest is likely to get discovered
even through a simple google search and
that hardly works for other social
platforms like instagram and twitter etc
so i have an example over here
you can see if i search frame designs on
google
two out of top six results are from
pinterest so reason number two
collaboration so pinterest is a great
platform for creators to grow together
using one of its best features and that
is group boards a group board is
basically like a combined feed of
multiple creators so whatever content
you all make you can also share it in a
group board you are a part of and if a
lot of people are following that group
board you all will consistently get
traffic from it and finally the last and
the most important reason and that is
monetization
according to a research by sprout social
85 percent of the people who see
something on pinterest eventually end up
buying it so pinterest is a highly
visual and attractive platform so when
people see something on it they end up
buying it i have seen so many people
post design mockups on pinterest with
links which lead back to their actual
paid mockups so you can add a link to
every post on pinterest which could lead
to thousands of leads and sales heck
people are making loads of money by just
putting affiliate links in their pins so
here is a wrap-up of why you should
start using pinterest as a creator in
2021 it is much easier to get discovered
on pinterest if you know how using group
boards you won't be alone in this
journey of growing your pinterest
account if your content is great
monetization on pinterest is a piece of
cake if you are interested in learning
more please sign up to the pinterest for
creators workshop you can find the link
to the workshop in the description below